I said I wanted to do three things with you today.
I said I wanted to tell you the "Awesome" story,...
...I want to share with you the three A's of "Awesome".
They are attitude, awareness, and authenticity.
I'd love to just talk about each one briefly.
So attitude.
Look, we're all gonna get lumps, and we're all gonna get bumps.
None of us can predict the future...
...but we do know one thing about it and that's that it ain't gonna go according to plan.
And when that bad news washes over you, and when that pain sponges and soaks in,...
...I just really hope you feel like you've always got two choices.
One, you can swirl and twirl and gloom and doom forever,...
...or two, you can grieve and then face the future with newly sober eyes.
Having a great attitude is about choosing option number two,...
...and choosing, no matter how difficult it is, no matter what pain hits you,...
...choosing to move forward and move on and take baby steps into the future.
The second A is awareness.
Having a sense of awareness is just about embracing your inner three-year-old,...
...because you all used to be three years old.
That three-year-old boy is still part of you.
That three-year-old girl is still part of you.
They're in there.
And being aware is just about remembering...
...that you saw everything you've seen for the first time once, too.
The last A is authenticity.
It's just about being you and being cool with that.
And I think when you're authentic, you end up following your heart,...
...and you put yourself in places and situations...
...and in conversations that you love and that you enjoy.
You meet people that you like talking to.
You go places you've dreamt about...
...and you end up following your heart and feeling very fulfilled.